[Musique]
en février
c'est mon père
[Musique]
donc
c'est un homme d'affaires c'est un éditeur c'est
un intellectuel
et il a beaucoup d'amis euh comme des écrivains des
poètes comme des éditeurs ils ont tous été emmenés
et ont
disparu de force et je suppose aussi
qu'il  peut être une cible du gouvernement
parce qu'il a publié beaucoup de livres
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
ma [
Musique] [Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
il a été condamné à 15 ans dans un  prison
sous les
accusations de toutes les étoiles d'incitation à subvertir
le
gouvernement, donc cette euh incitation à la
subversion de la subversion du gouvernement
cette
étiquette est très courante, la tendance des étiquettes est
utilisée pour gifler tous les
prisonniers politiques
et qui essaie juste de s'en aller comme
juste
juste euh juste  éliminer
votre langue et nous avons rompu nous étions
l'éducation
et nous étions les principaux uber
intellectuels est l'objectif principal de la Chine
ici non pas parce qu'il n'y en a
pas parce qu'il y a une sorte de
banlieue de contenu dans ces livres
ils ont pris tant de professeurs tant de
les écrivains les chanteurs
aiment les garçons les éditeurs donc
en ce moment comme ils aiment totalement effacés
comme une plus grande langue
de l'ira de l'école les
universités il n'y a pas de plus grand
journal même pas de magazine
tout est chinois et même
parler une plus grande langue à l'école est
interdit
machine
[Musique]